[Music]
today's question comes from jose in
brazil and jose writes i currently earn
45 to 50 000 a year working for a law
firm and i have some clients on the side
i'm debt free i have a 12 month
emergency fund invest 20 of my income
and i live with my mother while i'm
saving for a home down payment and to
pay for a small wedding
i have trouble spending money on myself
consider myself generous but when it
comes to spending money on me i'm
paralyzed i desperately need a new
computer but i worry about things on the
news shows so i save my money instead
it's like i always found an excuse to
not spend money now i'm anxious about
taking on a mortgage when i get married
how can i get over this mental block
ah
what do you think dave
i got all kind of feelings
[Laughter]
um
turn off the new shows
there's one
um
because they're skewing your view of the
future
and they're um
just about all of them have turned into
the national enquirer
i mean case in point the leading news
stories
on all the major networks which used to
be credible is ufos
so i mean the national enquirer has now
invaded every one of them
um so i mean seriously we had a slow
news day
or if you were biden and you wanted to
throw something shiny out and cause
people look at it right quick let's just
have a testimony before senate on ufos
in case somebody would look at that
instead of gas prices you know
so um oh my gosh so anyway so i i no get
away from that crap i remember this
um person not specifically but from my
days back working with law students and
it was a very common sentiment that i
think we can all have some sort of yeah
i can see that which is
a manic
powerful i'm going to accomplish this so
that i can get this so that i can get
this so that when i get wherever it is
i'm going i'm finally going to go ah
and this guy got ah and it doesn't exist
because if you're not dealing with the
underlying anxiety
which is this young man comes from a
situation where there was a lack of
safety i can guarantee you this young
man comes from a place where um
relationships were something that were
done to him they were not
there was not engagement there i can
guarantee you and he is trying to solve
that rattling that goes on inside his
body with this and with this and i'm
gonna double the emergency fund i'm
gonna invest even more i'm gonna
i'm gonna get married i'm gonna buy a
house i'm gonna have a computer i'm
gonna do clients and then i'm gonna have
clients on the side i'm gonna do it all
and here's what's happened you're just
gonna have a bigger collapse because at
the end of the day you gotta pay the
piper which is you got to heal
and so
the getting it's not getting over this
particular mental block it's healing
your body and it is healing your
approach to how you do life now some of
the some of the pushback i get on this
dave
dude there's a lot of problems in the
world and we need some really great
attorneys out there we need some great
innovative people that need to work
really hard for over a long period of
time i want people to be ambitious to
work really hard but i want people to
know that
that's not going to solve you
healing and relationships and running
hard can all be done at the same time
well as you say in one of your talks
winning
does not make you well that's right
so you can win the super bowl and you
still have to go home with you there you
go and you you cross the finish line and
then you look around go for what right
for what and so jose here's what i want
you to do man um yes you need to spend
some money and so right now you need
some discipline you're gonna have to
change your identity and we've talked
about that you have to change who you
see yourself as right now you see
yourself as this frugal guy who's a
planner and
you gotta change your
identity brother and you got to be
somebody who is generous and who enjoys
life and you don't know how to do that
so you got to practice it
and
i want you to begin healing from this
anxiety because this has been a long
time coming my guess is living at home
with mom may not be the best thing for
you right now and so that may be step
one of practicing this is getting your
own place even paying rent which is
gonna slow down your down payment i'm
good with that
uh but that's a lot of me reading into
somebody that i've never talked to
before what do you think dave
yeah i'm reading in i mean i believe in
hard work i believe in getting it i do
pretty much yeah i do too i do pretty
much everything wide open
but i have learned to get a little
rhythm where there's some margin and i
have a moment where i just sit and
breathe
and um i don't have to do it for two
hours every day
but i have to do it every so often i
mean sunday is a good time as an example
there's a reason for a sabbath right and
um so you need some rhythm where you
just breathe
or you just sit and breathe
and uh and and not turn turn turn turn
turn turn turn turn which means you
don't don't have any screens in front of
you while you're breathing screens don't
help you breathe and uh news channels
for sure don't help you breathe
so
my time with you dave
as hard as you run
and i'm simple i love i love going hard
i love going like i like just getting it
done and get it done
i've never got a sense from you that if
i win over here and i increase my net
worth that
my employees are all going to be well my
leadership team is going to be great and
my marriage can be perfect
you invest equally and i got to make
sure we're having these conversations i
got to make sure we say this again and
we say it again we say it again we're
training these people so this is awesome
and it's important and it's not the
end-all be-all right yeah i mean there's
just a there's a difference between
frying yourself out and working hard
that's exactly i love that what it comes
down to and it has to do with the margin
and the rhythm
and some sabbath and the peace
you need a purpose yeah you have a time
where you consciously realize every so
often and it's not once a year
but it's not once a day necessarily but
where you consciously breathe in
and you just feel peace yeah for a
second which means nothing's bothering
you for a second they'll be playing to
bother you later don't worry about it
it'll come around
but but i mean you just it because that
that what that is is what we're
discovering and craig rochelle and i
were talking about this on his
leadership podcast a little while back
um
that one of the things we're discovering
is that during the pandemic those of us
that were doing business
during the quarantines and the shutdowns
and the economic disruption and
the alien invader called fouchy and
all of these things i think he was
actually why they were doing those alien
testimonies before senate but um i think
he's actually an alien but i'm i'm gonna
personally invite him back but yeah but
the uh uh but any i mean he does well
anyway the uh
in the middle of all that we
you know we were like ah we're gonna get
through this you know you know hold your
breath grit your teeth push through
we're gonna fight through we're gonna
survive this thing we're not gonna lose
everything you know we're going to do
what it takes we're going to be
proactive and
and frenetic if we need to and what
craig and i were talking about was it
just burnt everybody down to their last
fuse there you go and instead of
instead of just
getting back to normal
you have before you can get back to any
kind of version of normal you got to
fill the tank back up because you
drained it to nothing a bunch of us i
was going to say you but i did yeah i
did that too and i so i spent you know i
started talking to craig craig and i
started talking about that about he's
one of the best leaders i know
one of the largest churches in america
he's a wonderful pastor and we were
talking about this just over dinner back
about six or eight months ago and ever
since then i went okay i got to make
sure i'm filling the tank back up and
just make a conscious effort because if
you're just running on constant gear on
gear with no oil you just fry the thing
out dude so that's what's going on here
jose that'll help you do this that'll
help you relax and then you'll spend
money